this is a recap of my workshop called
let go of your poi which was just a
general let's cover a lot of ground with
tosses the purpose of the workshop was
to open up the doors to people who have
not really played with it that much and
show them but there's so much
possibility especially the current
encourage their own imagination so first
thing I did was briefly looked at the
different types of pauses this is mostly
stuff people covered in other points
during the festival so underhand toss is
over here toss is under toss helicopter
throws throws yeah like switches to the
head of the poi just mention briefly
yeah you can like switch around your
body in different places okay then I did
a recap of my Nobi workshop very very
quickly totally should cover more
technique but I talked about different
types of tosses like this I think of us
backward and then the forward is this
one there's three different types
slapping down at the hands open with the
palm like that
landing in Reverse script like that we
like went through some no meat circuits
that we covered like just doing split up
backward tosses on the wall played
horror talks behind we looked at
patterns like this just like the one one
we looked at weeds as well which is just
simply practicing this exercise sort of
encouraging trying to touch our body
there's there's this position can use
any of those positions to transition
from one side of knowing tosses to
another I'm gonna change sides you can
choose to use any of those four on your
way over just use that lasted before
I'll use maybe the first to floor it all
the way over I think that's pretty much
nobody works top that's most of it okay
you know we're top here we covered so
much and I don't remember any of it
he'll be the bone but we tried this
thing fitting it into patterns it's kind
of fun challenging so much you can do
with that as well play with adding in
nobody tosses to it
meltdown no bees oh yeah talk about this
one she's really simple just doing this
like John do John switch hands switch
hands
when on top doesn't know me toss this
one on bottom just flips you do this
behind your back
switch over this one really good to know
there was a note there this one that you
can actually do another degree of twist
there was this one go around with
I like it with the so recently toss it's
nice toss it all over the place they're
just of the many different worlds of
glosses if you're trying kind of toss
think about what else is possible and
negative space like there are probably a
few hundred tosses that I've seen that
involve negative space
because my end up there yeah we just
talked about like when he had entrances
exits this one right looks through there
just floats down into that hands I think
you're talking about this one take that
into fire you can use that same one this
nice little timing switch also in excess
run two in one hand sending side
so many entrances and exits to my hand
you with you all kinds of stuff
that's the cover this guy she's like you
don't toss done
little there's so much
these houses you attack so just like it
also covered what else
there is more and I hope that anything
that comes out of this workshop you just
realize that there's just so much to
explore Joe graph see it this really
awesome idea I was doing that showing
this toss and you made me realize that
you can send this second leg tummy to
learn later and I'm really excited about